E
TO PRIME.
PRIME.IF YOU ARE WATCHING TONIGT
AWARE THAT THERE IS A WAR ON THE
AMERICAN WAY OF LIFE WHERE
ANYONE WHO BELIEVES TRUTHS LIKE
FAITH OR FREEDOM OR THE FLAG OR
THE FACT THAT GEORGE WASHINGTON
AND THOMASEFFERSON AND TEDDY
ROOSEVELT ARE GOOD PEOPLE LIKE
YOU ARE THE ENEMY.
AS ABRAHAM LINCOLN SAID SHALL WE
EXPECT SOME TRANS-ATLANTIC
MILITARY GIANT TO STEP THE OCEAN
AN CRUSH US AT A BW?
NEVER.
ALL THE ARMIES OF EUROPE, ASIA
AND TRANSFER INFANTRY CAN A
COMBINED WITH ALL THE FRESH OF
THEIR EARTH IN THEIR MILITARY
CHES WITH A BONE APART FOR A
COMMANDER COULD NOT BYORCE
DRINK FROM THE OHIO OR MAKE A
TRACK ON THE BLUE RIDGE IN A
TRIAL OF AHOUSAND YEARS.
IF DANGER EVER REACH US, IT MUST
SPRING UP AMONGST US.
IT CANNOT COME FROM ABROAD.
IF DESTRUCTION BE OUR LOT WE
MUST OURSELVES BE OUR AUTHOR AND
FINISHER.
AS A NATURE OF FREE MEN W MUST
LIVE THROUGH ALL TIME OR DIE BY
SUICIDE.
HE WAS JUST 28 YEARS OLD WHEN HE
SAID THIS.
ALL THINGS THE GREAT EMANCIPATOR
SAW THE TRUTH, DEATH BY SUICIDE
WAS THE CATASTROPHE FACING THE
REPUBLIC THEN AND IT IS SADLY
THE SAME TODAY.
THE ENEMIES OF THE AMERICAN WAY
SEEK TO STOKE OUR DIVISIONS,
SCHISMS AND SICKNESSES IN
PURSUIT OF THEIR OWN AGENDA.
THEY USE ALL THE TOOLS AT THEIR
DISPOSAL, MONEY, MIPULATION,
AND EVEN OPEN PROPAGANDA TO
WEAKEN OUR COUNTRY IN EVERY W.
THOSE URGING US TOWARD NATIONAL
SUICIDE DON'T JUST COME FROM
WITHIN, THEY ARE BACKED FROM
ABROAD.
AND N FOREIGN POWER IS A BETTER
FRIEND, ALLY AND MASTER OF THIS
EFFORT TO DRIVE AMERICA TO
SUICIDE THAN THE COMMUNIST PARTY
OF CHINA.
TH C IS ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN
AN EFFORT TO UNDERMINE OUR WAY
OF LIFE.
ITS REACH EXTENDS INTO OUR
BUSINESSES, OUR SPORTS, OUR
EDUCATION AND OUR GOVERNMENT.
WE SHOULDN'T BE SURPRISED BY
THIS.
THE COMMUNISTS AFTER ALL.
SUBVERSION IS WHAT THEY DO AND
THEY GET BORED SUBJECT GATING
THEIR OWN PEOPLE.
BUT CHINA IS DOING THIS WITH THE
ACTIVE COOPERATION OF OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS.
THEY ARE PARTNERS IN THIS
PROJECT AREN'T JUST MONOVALENT
SPIES DUFUS CONGRESSMAN.
IT'S OTHER THAN OUR OWN CULTURAL
AND BUSINESS ELITES WHO THEY
HAVE BOUGHT ANDAID FOR A
THOUSAND TIMES OVER.
OUR ELITES OPERATE HAND IN GLOVE
WITH THE COMMUNIST PTY OF
CHINA DOING ITS BIDDING EVEN
WHEN IT HARMS THE FREEDOMS AND
RIGHTS OF EVERY AMECAN.
WE SEE IT ALL THE TIME.
WE SEE IT WHEN AMERICAN MOVIE
STARS JOHN SIENA ISSUE CRINGING
APOLOGIES.
LEBRON JAMES NBA BEND OVER
BACKWARDS TO AVO OFFENDING THE
CHINESE COMMUNISTVEN WHEN THE
FANS CHINESE.
APPLE EAGERLY COOPERATE WITH
COMMUNIST TO CREATE A INTERNET
BETTER DESIGNED TO SUPPRESS
HUMAN FREEDOM.
WE SEE IT WHEN AMERICAN
UNIVERSITIES TOLERATE THE
EXISTENCE OF COMMUNIST
CONTROLLED NETWORKS TO SUPPRESS
FREE SPEECH ON CAMPUS.
WE SEE IT WHEN AMAZON.COM BARACK
OBAMA PRESS FLACK JAY CARNEY
PARTNERS WITH COMMUNIST
ENFORCERS TO TAKE DOWN NEGATIVE
REVIEWS OF THE CHINESE
DICTATOR'S BOOKS.
WE SEE IT WHEN THE WALT DISNEY
COMPANY AND CREDITS TO ITS 2020
LIVE ACTION FLOP MULAN PUBLICLY
THANKED COMMUNIST CHINESE
SECURITY ORGANIZATIONS IN JING
JONG A LITERAL GENOCIDE OF
UYGHURS.
WE SEE IT IN INTEL ISSUES A
CRAVEN APOLOGY TO THE COMMUNIST
PARTY OF CHINA FOR ADHERING TO
AMERICAN SANCTIONS.
WE SEE IT WHEN TOP SCIENTISTS AT
TOP UNIVERSITIES TURN OUT TO
HAVE BEEN DOING THE BIDDING OF
THE C FOR YEARS, HIDING THEIR
PAYOFFS IN THEIR LUGGAGE.
WE SEE IT WHEN BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION BUREAUCRATS PANIC
OVER A MAP SHOWING TAIWAN A
DIFFERENT COLOR FROM CHINA AND
CUT THE VIDEO TAIWANESE
SUBPOENAINGER AT FRAUDULENT
SUMMIT FOR DEMOCRACY.
THESE AREN'T ABSTRACT MATTERS OF
NATIONALTANDING OR GREAT
POWER.
THE COMMUNIST PARTY OF CHINA IS
REACHING DIRECTLY INTO THE
BRIC OF AMERICAN LIFE.
ESE ARE THE SPORTS YOU
WATCHER, THE PRODUCTS YOU B,
THE COMPANIES WHERE YOU WORK.
THE MOVIES YOU STREAM AND THE
SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES WHERE YOUR
CHILDREN LEARN IN 2021 ONE
INSTITUTION WILLING TO STAND UP
TO CCP, THE WOMEN'S TENNIS
ASSOCIATION.
FACED WITH THE OBVIOUS QUEUE
SIGH IMPRISONMENT OF CHINESE
TENNIS PLAYER ACCUSED A OFFICIAL
OF ASEXUAL ASSAULTED.
THE WTA BODY ON THE PLANET AND
SUSPENDED CHINESE OPERATIONS.
LOST OUT ON HUGE REVENUE AND
GROWTH OPPORTUNITIES.
WHY?
BECAUSE THERE WAS SOMETHING THE
COMMUNIST COULD NOT BUY FROM
THEM.
DECENCY, DIGNITY AND THE TRUTH.
I ASK YOU DON'T WHO WILL STAND
AGAINST THE COMMUNIST PARTY OF
CHINA?
NOT OUR GOVERNMENT, NOT OUR
ELITES, NOT OUR TECH FIRMS, NOT
OUR UNIVERSITIES, NOT OUR
CELEBRITIES, NOT OUR
ENTREPRENEURIAL GENUSSOUSES OR
TITA.
WOMEN'S TENNIS ASSOCIATION DID.
GOD WHETHER HE IS THEM FOR IT
BUT THEY AREN'T ENOUGH.
ARE YOU GETTING IT YET?
DO YOU SEE HOW THEEXUS BETWEEN
OUR CORRUPT ELITES AT HOME AND
THE COMMUNIST PARTY OF CHINA
ABROAD MAKES THEM EFFECTIVELY
THE SAME.
DO YOU SEE THAT FIGHTING ONE
MEANSIGHTING THEM BOTH?
MANY CONSIDER WHY DOES THE
COMMUNIST PARTY OF CHINA CARE SO
MUCH ABOUT SUBVERTING AND ENDING
AMERICAN FREEDOM?
PARTLY PLAYING POLITICS IF YOU
ARE SCHOOLED IN THE POLITICS OF
TH ZERO SUM WORLD, YOUR LOSS IS
MY GAIN.
SOMETHING MORE THAN THAT MOSTLY
THEY DO IT BECAUSE THE COMMUNIST
PARTY OF CHINA BELIEVES IT IS
LOCKED IN A LIFE OR DEATH
STRUGGLE WITH THE UNITED STATES
AND UIKE US, IT ACTS
ACCORDINGLY.
NEARLY A DECADE AGO, THE
COMMUNIST LEADERSHIP GATHERED TO
DISCUSS THE WORLD SITUATION AND
CHINA'S PLACE IN IT THE RESULT
OF THIS PARTICULAR MEETING WAS A
CIULAR COMMUNIQUE ON THE
CURRENT STATE OF THE IDEOLOGICAL
SPHERE BETTER KNOWN SIMPLY AS
DOCUMENT NUMBER 9.
DOCUMENT NUMBER 9 HAD ONE
PURPOSE AND ONE PURPOSE ONLY TO
T THE 90 MILLION MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNIST PARTY OF CHINA
KNOW WHO THE ENEMY IS.
HERE, ACCORDING TO THE CCP'S
GENERAL OFFICE ARE THE ENEMY'S
WEAPONS.
WESTERN CONSTITUTIONAL
DEMOCRACY.
WESTERN FREEDOM, DEMOCRACY AND
HUMAN RIGHTS.
CIVIL SOCIETY, INDIVIDUAL
RIGHTS, FREEDOM OF THE PSS,
THE SEPARATION OF POWERS, THE
MULTIPARTY SYSTEM, GENERAL
ELECTION, INDEPENDENT
JUDICIARIES AND NATIONALIZED
ARMIES.
ALL THESE THING ACCORDI TO
DOCUMENT NUMBER 9, ARE MORALITY
THROATS COMMUNIST RULE AND YOU
KNOW THEY ARE RIGHT.
THE PRINCIPLES AND INSTITUTIONS
UNDER GIRD AMERICA ARE MORALITY
THREATS TO COMMUNIST RULE AND TO
THE RULE OF TYRANNY EVERYWHERE.
THEY HAVE ALWAYS UNDERSTOOD THIS
SOMEMES BETTER THAN WE HAVE.
BUT THIS IS ALSO A LIST OF
THREATS TO SOMETHING ELSE.
IT'S A LIST OF THREATS TO THE
RULE OF OUR OWN ELITEOUR OWN CON
COMPLACENT POLITICAL CLASS.
ARE YOU AWAKE?
DO YOU SEE HOW THE THREAT AT
HOME AND THE THREAT ABROAD ARE
ONE IN THE SAME?
COMMON ENEMIES MAKE COMMON CAUSE
AND THEY DEPEND ON OUR DIVISIONS
TO RULE.
ESCRIPTIONS AT THE END OF
DOCUMENT NUMBER 9 CALL FOR MORE
FANATICAL CONTROL BY THE PARTY
OVER LIFE AND DISCOURSE BUT THEN
THERE IS THIS:  WE, IN THE
COMMUNIST PARTY OF CHINA, MUST
REINFORCE OUR MANAGEMENT OF ALL
TYPES AND LEVELS OF PROPAGANDA
ON THE CTURAL FRONT.
PERFECT AND CARRY OUT
ADMINISTRATIVE SYSTEMS AND ALLOW
ABSOLUTELYO OPPORTUNITY OR
OUTLETS FOR INCORRECT THINKING
OR VIEWPOINTS TO SPREAD.
WHAT WE KNOW NOW THAT WE DIDN'T
QUITE GRASP IN 2013 WHEN
DOCUMENT NUMBER 9 WAS ISSUED, IS
THAT THIS WASN'T JUST AN
IMPERATIVE WITHIN CHINA.
THE CCP INTENDED THEN AND NOW TO
CONTROL INCORRECT THINKING OR
VIEWPOINTS AS IT DEFINES THEM IN
AMERICA STILL AND SHAMEFUL AS IT
IS, THEY FOUND PLENTY OF
AMERICAN PARTNERS WHO FEEL
EXACTLY THE SAME WAY.
THIS IS THE BIGGEST THREAT
FACING AMERICA TODAY NOT RUSSIA,
NOT ISLAMIC TERRORISM NOT EVEN
THE VERY REAL THREATS ON OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THIS EXTERNAL THREAT IS
EXISTENTIAL BECAUSE IT IS
AMPLIFIED BY ITS ALLIANCE WITH
THE MAJOR INTERNAL THREAT FACING
AMERICA.
THE MALIGNED UNION OF LEFTIST
AUTHORITARIAN ELITES WHO SEEK TO
CORRODE THIS COUNTRY FROM
WITHIN.
THERE ARE SOME, EVEN SOME
CONSERVATIVES, WHO BELIEVE THE
INTERNAL THREATS WE FACE ARE SO
GREAT WE CANNOT HOPE TO WIN THIS
FIGHT.
THEY ARGUE WE MUST FOCUS ON
OURSELS THAT OUR ELITES IN
LEADERSHIP ARE TOO INCOMTENT
TO CONTEND WITH COMMUNIST CHINA.
I GET IT.I HAVE BEEN SOUNDING TM
ON FECKLESS AND MILITARY ELITES
FOR YEARS.
THE TRUTH THEY FAIL TO
UNDERSTAND IS THAT IN THE CASE
OF COMMUNIST CHINA, THE INTERNAL
AND EXTERNAL THREAT ARE ONE AND
THE SAME.
THE FIGHT AGAINST OUR CORRUPT
RRENDER MINDED ELITES IN
ACADEMIA, IN GOVERNMENT, IN
BUSINESS, IN SPORTS, IN MEDIA
AND BEYOND, ISNSPHRABLE FROM
THE FIGHT AGAINST A COMMUNIST
CHINESE LA VIA ON THIS THAT
FUNDS, DIRECTS AND ENCOURAGES
THEM.
THE MONOLITHIC UNION OF AMERICAN
AND COMMUNIST CHINESENTERESTANDR
NATIONAL LIFE FOR THE PAST
GENERATION MUST END.
AMERICAN FIRMS THAT COOPERATE
WITH COMMUNIST CHINESE
REPRESSION MUST SUFFER PENALTIES
INCLUDING CRIMINAL ONCE IF NEED
BE.
AMERICAN FIRMS THAT OUTSOURCE
SULY CHAINS IN MANUFACTURING
TO COMMUNIST CHINA MUST MOVE TO
FRIENDLY COUNTRIES OR BETTER YET
BRING THEM BACK HOME.
AMERICAN SPORTS AND FILM STARS
WHO KOWTOW TO COMMUNIST DEMANDS
SHOULD SUFFER PUBLIC SHAME.
AMERICAN UNIVERSITIES MUST CEASE
ALL COOPERATION WITH COMMUNIST
CONTROLLED INSTITUTIONS, HAVE
ZE TOLERANCE FOR COMMUNIST
CONTROLLED NETWORKS AND
INFORMERS ON THEIR CAMPUSES AND
IDEALLY NOT EDUCATING PRC
CITIZENS AT ALL.
AMERICAN GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRACIES SHOULD BE
COMPELLED TO STOP FUNDING AND
COOPERATING WITH COMMUNIST
BUREAUCRACIES AND INSTITUTIONS.
THE WUHAN INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY
SOUNDS LIKE A GOOD PLACE TO
START.
DO THESE THINGS OR EVEN THREATEN
THEM, AND THE CRY GOES UP FROM
E ELITES YOU WILL HURT
AMERICAN JOBS AND PROSPERITY IF
YOU CUT OFF COMMUNIST CHINA.
THIS IS THE SUICIDE NOTE LINDEN
DENOUNCED.
WE SHOULD NOTAVE TO SEN THE
DOMINANCE OF COMMUNIST CHINA AS
THE PRICE TAG FOR OUR AMERICAN
WAY OF LIFE.
IT IS ALSO A LIE.
THE UNITED STATES VIRTUALLY NO
TRADE FROM MAINLAND CHINA 1949 9
CLEAR THROUGH INTO THE 1990s
AND MANAGED TO CONDUCT THE
WOD'S HIGHEST STANDARD OF
LIVING WITHOUT THEM.
SO, LET'S DO IT AGAIN.
FOR ALL THAT WE HAVE BEEN AND
MEANT, WE CANNOT LOOK AWAY FROM
THIS FIGHT.
THE ENEMY IS HERE NOW.
HE COMMANDS THE HEIGHTS OF
HOLLYWOOD, SILICON VALLEY AND
WALL STREET.
IS HE POISONING OUR PEOPLE AND
BODY AND MIND.
HE MAY PUT JEFF BEZOS OVER HIS
KNEE TO DEMAND FIVE STA REVIEWS
BUT HE DOES NOT COMMAND US.
WE ARE AMERICANS, WE ARE WIDE
AWAKE.
AND WE ARE READY TO FIGHT FOR
OUR SCHOOLS, FOR OUR GOVERNANCE,
FOR OUR CULTURE, THE FUTURE DOES
NOT BELONG TO YOU AND NEITHER DO
WE.
OUR MINDS A